[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the the class
today
and today what I want to do is introduce
you to a lot of the openings briefly
introduce you to most of the openings
that we have the most popular openings
and then we also going to do lots of
tactical ideas sacrifices deflections
we're going to do double checks and many
different positions if you were here
last Sunday something similar we're
going to work on and some other new
things as well first I want to introduce
you to the ten openings that you can
play with the white pieces as white okay
so when you open up the game with the d4
in this position and this is a move for
example that I play and black can play
approximately ten different openings so
I would like to introduce you the first
few moves of each opening okay so the
first opening against d4 is d5 so when
you start the game you should play
either d4 or efore because these are the
two best moves in this position so I
will also go or some before opening but
first let's start out with d4 when you
play d4 black plays d5 c4 d takes c4
anybody familiar with this opening raise
your hand if you're familiar yes
aha okay good I mean you can play like
this that's good okay let's see all
right yes what's the name of this
opening Queen's Gambit but you have to
say something else Queens gambit
accepted okay this is the Queens gambit
accepted opening because he's accepting
he's taking the path so remember when
you take the pawn this is called Queens
gambit accepted okay
I will be checking this so I want
everybody to pay attention okay so now
there is a very nice trap that I want to
show you and you can use this actually
to win some games if your opponent is
not familiar with it so you play III now
you try to take the pawn here the best
ball in this position is to play Knight
f6 and just kind of give up the pawn and
just try to develop but some players
will try to protect this farm because
they they win upon they try to protect
it but this is a bad move already now
you play a for putting pressure on b5
and now if you place a six it's bad
because you capture and black captures
your winning the rook okay so that's why
it's not a good idea to play a six now
most likely your opponent will play c6
here and now you take and now I have a
question for you here white to play can
you find a winning move here white is
winning a piece now if you find the
right move here it's not so easy to sit
because it's a kind of an unusual move
but black weakened his position here
especially he weakened to the diagonal
and as you can see you need to find a
piece that is not protected and trying
to attack that piece here it's a it's a
nice trap here and white is winning a
piece okay let's give you a little bit
more time try to see how can you what
can you play here to win the piece okay
yes
quint where
very good Queen f3 and now you're
attacking the rook because diagonal is
very weak and now he cannot really
protect this rook if he plays Bishop d7
you can just take the bishop so it's not
good for him so he has to play 96 but
now you simply take Czech Bishop d7 and
queen eight six and white is up a piece
in this position okay if you'll see if
you take the rook see the quid is
already protecting it that's why so you
just go here and you're up the night
here so let's go back again and take a
look again so this the name of this
opening is what's the name Queens ah-huh
murder there we can have two to
different it's similar yes Queen's
Gambit except it okay so remember this
is the Queens gambit accepted opening
because when you take the pawn that's
the accepted okay next opening I show
you it's going to be the Queens gambit
declined where is declining taking the
pawn
so again when he takes yours you play
III the idea behind this move is to
protect your Center and also open the
diagonal for the bishop now it plays b5
you play a for attacking he plays if you
place a six you simply capture captures
and you win the rook and if you place c6
you take he takes and Queen f3 that's a
very strong move it's a trap and I
actually want some games myself also
with this idea so but since we're on
this opening I want to just ask you a
question here in this position for
example in this position
white to play can you find a winning
move here the idea here is double attack
you make a move and you attack two
different pieces at the same time and
it's very difficult to defend so now if
white white to play and win here okay
yes very good move Queen to f3
because again same idea in this opening
you should always look for this move
Queen f3 this is the second time we see
that this is a good idea because now we
are attacking on f7 and also attacking
the rook at the same time so this idea
called fork and double attack okay when
you attacking two things at the same
time full or double attack here and
white is winning okay so let me check
again one more time when he takes what's
the name of this opening let's raise
your hand if you know it raise your hand
if you know the opening okay yes and I
accept it okay Queens gambit accepted
okay most of you already familiar with
this opening now I want to move on to
the next opening okay the next opening
here is e 6 and since he is not taking
the pawn what's the name of this opening
excellent Queens gambit declined okay
this is not a very popular opening and
many world champions play this defense
sometimes I also play myself in
tournaments so in this opening white
usually plays Knight out
93 9 F six
and you want to get your nine out to f3
question for you is it a good idea to
play this move immediately here no why
why it's not a good idea to play this
one because looks like a normal move
just protecting the center but why you
think this is not a good idea
very good very good point because you
don't want to block this Bishop you
always want to get this Bishop out first
and then play e3 okay so that's why you
want to you don't want to play this move
III okay so what you want to do first
you have to do this move first and then
play III which move you have to play
first here for white raise your hand if
you know it raise your hand yes you
could play that move but usually what
you want to do in the early stage of the
game you don't want to develop the Queen
too early first get your minor pieces
out and again minor pieces are your
knights and bishops get your minor
pieces out castle and then think about
development what I want to do here I
want to go back for a moment and just go
over the first five steps if you were in
my class I've been teaching already a
few weeks and I talk about these steps a
lot so I want you to be familiar if
let's say your first time and there are
five very important steps when you start
the game the first step is to control
the center okay this four squares so I
will quickly review the steps with you
and some of you our first time here so
you will know so so when you start the
game you have to control the center so
that's why I recommend either to play
this move or this move because it helps
you to control the center so we control
the center now second step what is
second step okay yes
very good develop minor pieces and minor
pieces are your knights and bishops
remember right step number three what is
step number three okay castle because
safety of the King is very important
okay you can say it's your number one
priority when you play because you can
be have lots of material but if your
king is getting checkmated then you lose
the game so it's not about winning lots
of material but you have to make sure
your king is safe first so after that
now we finish step number three it's
council now step number four very
important what is step number four yes
finish development including major
pieces and what are the major pieces
Quinn and rooks Quinn and rooks okay
usually we don't develop the King we
just cancel with the King because King
is yeah just we have to make sure we
always protect the king okay so next
step step number four is complete the
development including the major pieces
something like this now I will show you
this is just an example of a game where
white is completing is developing
usually you in order to complete the
develop and you move the Queen up and
then you put your rooks in the middle
okay that's how you complete the
development of the major pieces and only
after you do that what is step number
five after you finish the control of the
center and now step number five start
the attack okay you only start the
attack now when you finish the
development and usually the way you
start the attack you advance your pawns
in the center if you can or you activate
your minor pieces towards the center
okay so this five steps is very
important to remember okay so now let's
go back to the our second opening Queens
gambit declined and you play ninety
three so before you play the movie three
you need to develop your Bishop right
now where you want to develop the dark
square Bishop when you develop this
please try to develop to an active
square okay
let's see yes where can you absolutely
both moves you can play but I recommend
you play Bishop g5 here because Bishop
one g5 is very active and it's going to
be putting pressure okay you go here and
now black cancels you play III and now
next would be to develop the light
square Bishop and castle okay this is
how you want to play against Queens
gambit declined you have your minor
pieces are your king is safe and then
the next idea would be to develop the
Queen
and you develop the queen and put the
rooks together and that way you have the
complete development okay so let's go
back and review this opening one more
time so white plays d4 d5 c-46 and
what's the name of this opening when
black plays is six we went over the
accepted right when he takes but when he
doesn't take you remember the name for
this opening yes
Queens gambit declined because he's not
accepting the pawn right he plays d6
declining it so it's Queens can be
declined
so now I want to see if you remember the
first few moves okay so raise your hand
if you remember the next move for white
here remember the setup just how we
develop the pieces here okay yes what's
the next move Knight to c3 Knight to f6
you just need to develop your pieces
okay so now which piece you want to
develop next raise your hand yes Knight
to f3 good it goes here now before we
play III remember before you play III
what do you want to do Bishop to g5 okay
now black castles now we also want to
castle soon we don't want to keep the
king in the middle of the board for a
long time but we have to develop our
Bishop first to do that so next off go
ahead
III write pawn to e3 now it goes here
now
where do we develop the bishop in the
Queens gambit declined opening in
general it's good for you to know that
in Queens gambit declined you always
develop your light-square bishop to the
d3 square when you play with the white
pieces your Bishop belongs on d3 usually
in this opening so we play Bishop d3 and
after he plays b6 next move go ahead
castle safety of the King and as you can
see the arrows are showing you the Queen
will go here next and then will go rook
F d1 through k c1 and white just
completed the development and after that
you can try to attack but try not to
attack it's very important you remember
the steps okay try not to attack too
early because your attack not going to
be very successful you need to have
better development so you can have a
successful attack yes what well it
depends either you attack with the pawns
if you have opportunity to advance the
pants you do that if you don't have that
opportunity you try to activate your
minor pieces but remember you want to go
towards the center very important okay
all right let's move on to the third
opening so so far we did Queens gambit
accepted and declined the third opening
I want to show you is this opening and
let's see if you know this opening very
popular opening actually one of the most
popular opening nowadays the top players
a lot of them they play this opening so
black place is six d4 d5 c4 c6 raise
your hand if you know this opening
anybody familiar with this opening okay
so it's it's a new opening for you
so it's called Slav defense okay
Slav defend the third opening its Slav
defense idea behind this opening black
tries to protect the center and the the
most simple way to play this opening and
try and you will have a slightly better
position is the line that I like to play
in fact when I play in tournaments and
somebody plays the Slav defense against
me I
ACON I play the slide I take its called
exchange variation of the sloth defense
okay so you take he takes now you
develop your knives as I mentioned
earlier nights before bishops right so
we just develop and again before we play
this move we need to get the bishop out
but remember in this opening your bishop
actually belongs on f4 not on g5 in
Queens gambit declined we play Bishop g5
but in the sloth defense your Bishop
belongs on f4 because now you will
control many important squares on this
diagonal okay so remember Queens gambit
declined the bishop belongs on g5 in a
sloth defense the exchange valuation you
put the Bishop on f4 okay I will review
this with you so now black has few
possibilities how to play here you can
play a six Bishop f5 or is six and now
you play III Bishop e7 you develop your
Bishop to d3 castles your castle and
again you have you finish step number
three after you cancel then you have an
open file and if you see an open file
you want to put your rook on that file
okay
so next step will be to play rook c1 and
you can again put your queen only two
here like for example if you place here
you can just put the clean only to a6 a
three to control the square because the
next idea is to play rock c2 and put the
other rope to c1 so you double up your
rooks on a C file and why it has a
slightly better position here
the main idea why because if you see
this Bishop is more active here then the
bishop on d7 which 47 is very passive or
black but your bishop your lights go
Bishop is more active here okay
so your idea will be to play this way
against this opening and rook c2 and
double up the rooks so let's go back and
go over this line again it's a new
opening for you so let's start again
d4 d5 c4 c6 now what is the name of this
opening you should know what's the name
note this is not the Queen's Gambit send
you one the third opening absolutely
this is a Slav defense okay and which
variation we play in against the Slav
defense and by the way if you if you're
thinking of learning some openings you
can actually play d4 you cannot if you
know if you like to learn before you can
play this this lines against the Queens
gambit accepted the client or sloth
defense so but which violation we play
against the sloth defense you remember
yes yes that's the move but remember the
name I mentioned the name of this line
okay let's see okay
when you take what do we call well you
take something exchanged right the
exchange variation of the sloth defense
now after you take now next step is to
develop your pieces right and let's see
if you remember how to develop here and
which pieces we develop first okay huh
mine are okay where where do we develop
minor pieces sure you want to develop
the Knights remember nights before
bishops okay go ahead yeah which piece
okay so Knight f3 right excellent
so it goes Knight f6 continue very good
now next Bishop f4 remember in this
opening the bishop belongs on f4 okay in
a Slav defense exchange variation the
bishop belongs on a fork very important
to remember okay because if you put the
bishop somewhere else you're probably
not going to have much advantage so
remember to clip the bishop on f4 nigh
place ecigs next move what is the
maximum for white because white also
wants to finish his development so you
can castle so what's the next move you
need to do
very good next you want to try okay now
you want to cast the right but you can't
do that right away yet so you need to
develop your bishop light square bishop
and remember also in this opening is the
same as the Queens gambit declined your
light square bishop belongs on d3
remember in a Slav defense exchange
variation also the bishop belongs on d3
so it goes here Castle and what is the
best proof of white now yes castle very
good when you see an open file what do
you do when you see an open file which
piece belongs to an open file rook so
you put the roof on the open file now
next
e - e - okay remember the notation it's
if you remember this it's going to be
very easy for you one and two it's
always for white okay white pieces go
one and two black pieces go seven and
eight okay so when you set up a board
make sure seven eight it's for black and
one and two for white okay to keep a
good notation so next next step is we
want to double up the rooks on a C file
right we want to do this both and here
but we play this move first why do we
play this move who can tell me what's
the idea behind this one why I play this
move first and for example I don't play
this immediately there is a detail here
that you need to know here okay yes in
the back here excellent very good if you
play immediately rook see - very good
part you play night before and now what
do we call this idea in chess continue
fork fork because now you bring the
night and now attacking the rook and a
bishop so it's not a good idea to play
this move that's why I played a3 first
so I control this square so when I play
rook see - he cannot play night before
now a three and let's go we stop here
but let's go a couple of more moves and
let's see if you remember the next two
moves here for white yes continue very
good an eye place here and now the final
move you need to play here right so
let's say yes in the back yeah
here or here
here because you want to put the roof
here because that's why we play this
roof up so we can double the rooks okay
when you have two rooks on the same file
you double the rooks and very important
because this is the open file so if we
put this roof somewhere else let's say
we put the rook here it's not going to
be a very good idea because look rook is
not going to be very effective because
it's blocked so you usually want to put
the rook on an open file it's very
important and if let's say also same
thing goes here
rook will be a little bit better placed
here because with some potential maybe
in the future to play before be five but
rook F c1 is your best move and white is
slightly better but I mentioned this why
white is slightly better I don't know if
you remember the main idea main reason
why white is slightly better is in the
beginning in the beginning gets will go
first that's important because when you
start again with white you have
advantage but I'm talking about
specifically in this position in this
position there is a reason why white is
slightly better because everything looks
kind of similar it's kind of symmetrical
also but there is one piece that I have
it's more active than the piece that
black has and that this is which bishop
absolutely if you look at the position
look at the possibilities of this bishop
compared to the bishop for black black
Bishop doesn't have any squares to go to
so it's very passive sometimes the
evaluation of the position could change
by just one piece here if you have
active piece and your opponent has the
passive piece it's an advantage for
white okay so this is the slab defense
and remember slab defense is the opening
in exchange variation okay remember that
okay
okay the next opening we're going to do
Knight f6 c4 g6 this is another very
popular opening Bishop g7 anybody
familiar with this opening it's probably
one of the most popular opening in chess
against d4 especially as a defense and
one of the best players garry kasparov
used to play this when he was playing
actively his best defense against e4 so
anybody familiar with this opening okay
so this opening hold Kings Indian
defense okay Kings Indian defense so
against this system there are many
different ways how white can play here
but I will show you a system that is
very simple and it's easy to play and
also you can obtain a slightly better
position again any all these lines that
I'm showing you actually this is how I
play against this opening so that's why
I'm very familiar with the dis lines
here so you play Knight f3 castles and
you play Bishop g5 this line is the
Kings Indian defense is the opening and
line it's called Smith's loss Petrossian
system okay because it's named after two
world champions Smith's love and
Petrossian they played a lot this system
so it's named after these two great
players so you play Bishop g5 and you
should be already familiar with this
idea because before we play this move in
most of our openings we get the bishop
out first right so we don't have a
passive bishop here so you play Bishop
g5 he plays d6 you play III
pay close attention because there is a
very nice trap then you can win some
games if you if you know this idea here
black goes here now in this opening
actually you don't put a bishop here in
a Kings Indian defense when you play The
Smiths love Petrossian system your
bishop actually belongs only to so there
are differences for you to know like in
for example Queens gambit declined and
Slav defense bishop belonging on d3 but
in this opening we play Bishop e2 so
there are differences that you need to
know
and now c6 the most natural move is to
cancel but you play this move first
because your Queen actually belongs on
c2 in this opening but at the same time
you set up a trap and now if black is
not careful you can fall into this trap
and get checkmated or lose upon so he
plays h6 Bishop g5 and in this opening
very often black tries to win this
Bishop try to force the bishop to go
back here and go here and try to
exchange this bishop so he can have the
pair of the bishops okay so when you
place knight h5 this is a blunder now
now let me give you a few minutes to
think here let's spend a minute or two
why to play can you find the tactical
idea you're going to either checkmate
him or win a pawn and get a winning
position here okay think about it if you
if you think you know it just
double-check your answer
I will check right now so this is the
trap now black already walked into the
trap
okay yes
Bishop to d6 if you do that but then he
takes now see he is defending it so
that's why we can do Bishop d6 here it's
something different here okay yes you
want to bring the bishop here you could
do that but this will be just a normal
move for you to play right here you have
something much stronger you have much of
it just just raise your hand okay okay
good okay so it's tactical idea okay
we're not just making a normal move it's
a tactical idea that you need to find
okay in the back yes excellent Mack
Knight g5 okay okay let's let's see now
why this is a strong move this is a very
strong move in fact I've played a lot of
games in this opening and many times
I've had the chance actually to win a
games
win games like this in blitz chess and
sometimes even in real tournaments
actually because if opponent is not
familiar with this idea
he can very easily fall into this trap
here and now Knight g5 let's see now
what's going to happen if he takes the
knight you simply take the night and now
you win upon and also position of the
black king is now very weak because now
the position is open here this point is
weak and you have very strong attacking
chances and if he doesn't take the
knight you have a question well yeah
okay just yeah so this is good you're a
pawn here okay but this is probably the
best thing he can do
and if he tries to take the bishop
thinking okay let me take this bishop
first let me take the bishop first and
then I take the knight so looks like it
will win a piece but now this one is
already a big blunder and now why to
play
quaint 2h7
very good checkmate okay say one in
accuracy and you can win again very
quickly here by knowing this drop in the
Kings Indian defense okay so that's why
you want to play like this in this
opening it's a good setup in general
even if it doesn't you know go for this
you know trap you know you still have a
comfortable position here I will show
you let's say if it doesn't play this
for example he plays a five your idea is
very simple you castle then you play
rook fd1 Lucchesi one and you complete
the development again all these openings
I'm showing you you're finishing your
development and then after that you try
to go for that attack so for example
here you will go Queen rook fd1 who
create through kc-1 I have been playing
this is this mr. Petrosian setup maybe
close to twenty years old in a
tournaments against this opening so I
played maybe close to 100 games in this
opening okay all right so let's go back
and review this system it's one of the
most popular defenses against d4 okay so
d4 Knight f6 c4g 693 Bishop g7 at this
point at this stage of the game we don't
even know the name of the opening yet
because he could play Bishop g7 which
will be the Kings Indian defense but he
can also play this move d5 which is
going to be a different opening grünfeld
defense another very popular opening
against this against d4 so that's why at
this point I didn't say the Kings Indian
yet so as soon as he plays the bishop on
g7 we know that this is already Kings
Indian defense and now you remember how
we play let's see if you remember the
setup now with the white pieces here how
we develop the pieces here for white
continue
remember what do we do usually in two
openings right the openings I'm showing
you normally which pieces come out first
nice usually come out first and then the
bishops come in right so the move is f3
castle now the next move okay go ahead
pawn to e3 so we have to play this boom
but we have to do something first
remember if we play pawn to e3
immediately our Bishop will be blocked
so we always want to get this Bishop out
first in our openings we get this Bishop
out first and then we play that yeah
very good
and after you play this move do you
remember the name for this system it's
named after two world champions what's
the name of this system yes
Smith Slav is the Russian portal
champion vasily smyslov and the second
is the world champion from Armenia where
I'm originally from you remember his
last name world champion number nine
okay okay okay very good so Smith Slav
Petrossian okay so because they the
reason it's called this way this line
because both players they played a lot
this system that's why you know it cause
mr. petrochine play a system here so
Bishop g5 d6
now continue what is the next move for
white okay not yet not yet remember you
got to get the pieces out first Queen c2
is coming up a little bit later okay go
ahead III so remember don't play for
here you know because you know if you
play before this is now it's already you
play something different okay so you
play with the system that I'm showing
you okay III this system now black cause
9b d7 can
Kinue and now let's see if you remember
now where your light square bishop
belongs in this opening see the other
two openings I show you your bishop
belonged on a different square but now
here yes very good bishop belongs on e
to here the reason it belongs here
because if you put the bishop on d3 in
general against the unchecked of Bishop
Bishop it's not very effective here
because it's kind of going to be
attacking this pawn but this pawn is
just protected it's always protected by
h7 and f7 so it's not very effective
here and that's why we play Bishop e2 in
this system now I play c6 the most
natural move here is to cancel but we
don't do that yet here we play another
developing move and set up the trap
let's see yes not sure okay go ahead d2
think about it d1 what Queen to queen is
on d1 already
your clothes your clothes yes see - okay
you want to put the Queen on see -
remember now it's not that we playing
this smooth just only hoping for the
trap we are still making a good move and
next move we're going to castle but we
also you know looking forward to this
possibility if it starts attacking your
Bishop h6 now this is the trap what do
you do now do you take the knight on f6
or you retreat here okay you Richard
right now I place g5 attacking the
bishop yes very good now when your
opponent plays these two moves it's a
very good chance now he's going to go
for the trap okay because you know
usually just players when they push your
bishop back on g3 they do this with this
idea to go here to try to get your
Bishop so it's a very good chance now
they're going to play this one and as
soon as they played this this is where
you do the tactical idea to checkmate
him or win upon okay let's see yes
Knight h5 wait Heep he played 9h 5g5
Knight takes g5 right you take the pawn
now he has two options his best option
is to take and after Bishop takes h5
he's down upon but he's also position of
the King is very weak so he is you know
in big trouble here but and if it takes
your Bishop what do you do now what do
you do if it takes its
you could take the night back but you
have something better you have something
better okay
Quinn yeah yeah Quinn 2 8 7 checkmate
right
it's a checkmate because you cannot take
it because the knight is protecting it
ok it's very important to remember Kings
Indian defense so let's go back now
let's review the line if let's say he
doesn't play you know he doesn't have to
always play this idea and lose because
of the trap let's say he plays the
normal move here what do we do now next
because your king is in the middle of
the board right you have to make sure
the king is safe right
you cannot just keep the king there yes
castle very good safety of the King is
very important now he plays here I have
a question for you did you finish the
development here already
can we start the attack know which
pieces we need to develop still rooks ok
very good
now where do we want to develop the
rooks it's this is actually a not so
easy to determine when you're playing
because sometimes it could be a little
bit confusing to see ok where do I
really put this rooks so but in this
position you put the rope on
rook fd1 very good so it plays here next
move
yes okay if you are playing against the
computer haha
you need to come to computer to follow
those you know Bishop and sometimes be
pain it's like that yeah yeah I'm gonna
file on that of them so it did make all
these new the computer is going to react
exactly well a to a certain point it's
hard to say it depends on what type of
computer using yeah yeah it depends how
strong the computer if Li if you play a
very strong computer like a strong
engine yeah they're not going to fall
for the trap they're not but the first
few moves it's it's going to happen
they're going to play Kings engine it's
a perfectly fine opening so you play
this move and then the next move is yes
yeah so the reason we put the rooks here
I was going to mention here that it's
not so easy to see where really belongs
you know where would we put the rooks
here because we can take here right for
example if it makes a move
potentially we can take take and now our
rook is already on an open file okay
so that's why you want to put the rook
there because after capture capture your
rook is already on open file okay okay
very good so there there are many more
openings that I want to work with you
but maybe next time we will continue
from where we are right now today we did
four different openings so let's do a
quick review of which four openings we
cover today
like I mentioned there are ten openings
so next class we're going to do that I
want to do now a little bit different
positions with yours okay at the end so
the first opening we did was he takes
and what's the name of this opening
raise your hand if you remember the
opening name raise your hand yes Queens
gambit accepted very good second opening
with it was
Queens gambit when they don't accept
your clothes decline okay they decline
your Queens can be declined
now the third opening is six six another
very popular opening let's see yes
yeah let's I asked her yet sloth defense
correct and the fourth opening today we
did is Kings Indian defense and we
played The Smiths love each Russian set
up against this opening okay okay very
good
you have a question no okay all right
that's what I thought you raise your
hand okay now we're going to do some
positions okay let me change this if I
set up this position here what would be
your first move here yes here
seven fork you fork the king and a queen
and you win the Queen and your upper
piece in the endgame so you will be
winning okay very good
so that's your idea you trying to do
here maybe this will be a hint for you
but okay just first one will be a little
bit easier but okay why to play now try
to think how you can make this idea work
okay okay
check your answer let's give you a
little bit more time to think white to
play and win a piece what can you do
here see you cannot play this move right
away here because if you go here he's
just going to take so it's not going to
work what can you do here okay yes not
sure okay yes go ahead could be eight
it's okay yeah this is you know a check
you check and I go here and you you made
a move but you're not winning here it's
just that you gave me a check okay but
you have something very very nice idea
you have okay I see lots of hands
excellent yes go ahead
very good Queen takes f6 nice
combination you always have to look for
this kind of ideas you sacrifice your
queen for the bishop
seems like wait a minute it's just going
to take right and you lost your queen
for the bishop it's a tomb of
combination okay you sacrifice your
queen but you eliminated the defender of
the e7 very important square right and
after that continue
very good
97 check for King the king and queen and
he has to come up Knight takes d5 white
is winning okay so the idea the team for
this is called removing the defender
okay where you remove the defender in
this position defender is the bishop so
you sacrifice your queen to remove the
defender and then you follow it up with
a 97 move okay okay white to play and
win one thing I want to mention to you
if you look at the position of the King
look at this palms you're an original
squares and he doesn't have a escape
square for this King so that means there
are some ideas for some potential
background checkmate ideas you have okay
but in order to do a background check
mate you need to deflect a piece very
important piece here so how can you that
there are many ways you can try to
attack this piece but only one way
effectively to deflect it that will
result into winning a piece at least
think about it a little bit don't rush
if you think you know it try to double
check your answer and try to look for a
defense also we try to find the best
attacking move but we need to also find
the defense
somehow if you deflect this piece right
you can take the rook and checkmate so
that's the idea that you're trying to do
here okay let's see raise your hand if
you think you have this idea this is a
difficult one it's not easy to see the
idea but you can find it you have to
look at our entire board okay don't just
focus on one side of the board look at
the entire 64 squares yeah okay first
move let's see go ahead Queen to f4 I
mean this is a deflection you're trying
to do but I don't I'm not forced to take
the Queen because if I take the idea of
the deflection is rook takes rook
checkmate but I'm not forced to take I
can just simply go back see and you're
not winning material so you have
something better you got the right idea
but now find a better square for your
queen that will result into winning some
material okay there is a better Square
to do that okay yes in the back yeah
okay let's see you not your you ready
aha Queen to f6 here but here's the pawn
pawn is guarding that square here so not
not quite going to work okay yes yeah
here
here aha okay this is also this is also
an interesting idea but again this is
not going to force me to take the Queen
if i take the Queen the idea works
checkmate but again this is not going to
force me I can just go back here and
you're not winning material okay
yes excellent that's the right move
Queen b7 now you put the Queen here
because not only now attacking the Queen
you also now putting pressure on the
knight
so if it takes the Queen what are you
going to do checkmate
rook takes d8 and if it doesn't take the
Queen let's say he moves back to defend
his last rank now in this line you just
win a piece what do you do to win the
piece here what do you do to win a piece
here it's the move order is very
important okay the move order is very
important here yes well if you take you
want to take immediately or you need you
want to do something first because look
if you take immediately I take your Rock
so you need to do something first you
make it in between idea yes take the
knight immediately aha so it's very
important you know before you rush to
take the piece make sure you find that
yeah go ahead well if you take Queen
takes Queen he goes here and now he
managed to survive without losing any
material here so you want to do
something else here first yes
you could do that but now your queen is
under attack right you ideas to win this
night ideas to win the night but first
first you need to do something yes
well now what we should be two again I
mean the Bishop e2 if I take the Queen
yes you can mate but I will take check
in between move check and you need to
find in-between move I eliminate your
knight and then I take the Queen ok so
in this position you actually need to
find it in between move first so you can
win this night you can take it right
away yet so yes
no Queen eight six you can take you can
take because the knight is protecting
the Queen okay
you could go look to anyone it's really
simple idea actually you're trying to
find more difficult ideas here try to
look for a simple idea instead of a
difficult just look simple idea let's
see simple idea first and then you take
the night to make sure nothing is
hanging okay let's see okay okay great
really you find more difficult ideas now
just take check now you force him to
take and now you take the piece and you
wrap a piece okay what when why he show
why this off to a see here yeah well the
the thing is he will take your rock with
the check and then he takes the plain
and black is up a rock so yeah we just
take okay so we take first on d8 make
sure our rook is not hanging we he takes
back and
then we take the night okay and white is
up a piece
winning all right let's do this again
this idea this is called deflecting
deflecting the defender here so what is
the first move here okay very good Queen
B seven now if he takes continue what do
you do if he takes continue yeah
checkmate good now if he goes back the
difficult move here let's see what do
you do first okay rook takes rook check
he has to take and now okay Queen takes
Knight
White is a per piece upper Bishop okay
so it's a winning endgame okay
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]